Muslim.
forch.
My dear brothers and sisters, we gather
today to
celebrate. Alhamdulillah. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala accept all of our
fasts and our my dear brothers and
sisters, the month of Ramadan has now
passed and it is which was a month in
which we draw nearer to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala through nothing more important
than the Quran. The Quran my dear
brothers and sisters is the Quran my
dear brothers and sisters is your life.
The Quran is your the Quran is what you
use to you is what you utilize to live
each and every single day of your life.
It is the between
you. It is the and the conversation
between you and your lord. It is the
that was given to the prophet Muhammad
sallallam. And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he says regarding the Quran that this
Quran that he guides to the most correct
way and the right
path and he gives glad tidings to the
believers who do work righteous good
deeds of a paradise. My dear brothers
and sisters, if you're wondering why
there are holes and missing things
within your life, if you are wondering
why there are things going wrong, then
it's no other for no other reason other
than the fact that you've gone away from
the Quran and that you've distanced
yourself from the Quran. The prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
going to complain on the day of judgment
and he's he's going to say,
He's going to complain to Allah and he's
going to say, "Oh my Lord, indeed my
people, they they forsake this Quran.
They distance themselves from this
Quran." My dear brothers and
sisters, the Quran is going to be either
a proof for you or a proof against you.
May Allah subhana wa ta'ala save us from
being those who the Quran is a proof
against. Especially for many of us who
claim or we say that we are born
alhamdulillah Muslim and we grow up in
Muslim countries and that we've learned
the Quran. How much of the Quran do you
implement in your life? Because there's
no other reason as to why the Sahabah
and the Quran, the the early generations
of the Muslims, the reason why they were
successful, the reason why they were
able to succeed in everything that they
did was because
their their connection with the Quran,
it used to be very strong. Any time even
during difficulties or during ease, they
would always have the Quran nearby. My
dear brothers and sisters, the Quran
should be something that you open every
single day. Every single day of your
life, you should be reading verses from
the Quran. Even if it's a page, even if
it's an ayah, every single day. Why?
Because the Quran is either going to be
or now my dear brothers and sisters, the
Quran is a shif. One of the names of the
Quran is it is a cure. Why? Because when
the hearts are diseased from sin and
haram that we do day and night, when you
open the Quran, you forget all about the
and the and the difficulties of the
dunya. And it's as if you enter a
different realm and you connect with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and you ponder
over his ayat.
Why is it? What makes it so difficult
for us to be able to ponder over the
Quran? Or is it that their hearts became
sealed? When you do that we do every
single day, a black dot is placed on our
heart until our whole heart is covered.
And there's nothing that can remove
these dots except for Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And there's no better way to get
nearer to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
other than the Quran. My dear brothers,
if you do not know how to read the
Quran, then the bare minimum should be
that you listen to its ayat, that you
read the translation, that you try to
understand its meaning. Why?
Because the Quran is that which guides
to the best things and the right way and
it gives glad tidings to the believers
for paradise. There's no other way to
Jenna. There's no other way to success
except through this Quran. This Quran,
it was used to raise people and put
other people down. This Quran was a
criterion and to establish what is right
and wrong. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
says in the
Quran Allah he tells us that this um is
the best of um it's the best of nations.
But why why is it that Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala preferred this um over all the
other
nations? Because
Because we enjoying the good and we
forbid the evil. We tell each other to
do the good things and we tell each
other to avoid the haram things. If you
have people in your life telling you to
do the right things, telling you to fear
Allah, kiss them on their head because
these are the people that's going to
help you get to Jenna. And if you have
people that are dragging you down and
that are trying to make uh trying to
organize even what they're going to do
on day from haram and they're trying to
draw you out. These are the people that
you need to distance because these are
the people that are going to take you to
the hellfire. Now my dear brothers and
sisters today is a day of today is a day
of happiness. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he brought us all together here to
together and to
witness together. My dear brothers and
sisters utilize this time to enjoy with
your friends and family and to thank
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for that which
he gave you and to praise him and to
give shuk to him and to give sodak for
the sake of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
for those who are less needy than who
are more needy than us. Likewise,
alhamdulillah, each and every single one
of us today, we came either through cars
or buses or we walked in Ammon in
security and safety and peace. And our
brothers and sisters in Palestine, they
don't even know if they're going to be
bombed or not. So remember the
difficulties that they're going through.
Remember the hardships that they're
going through and the ease that you
have. and ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to bring the joy back to those people to
make those kids smile to make those
those mothers look at their families and
smile and make those people happy make
dua that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
removes their difficulty and that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala destroys the Zionist
that are causing them harm
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala accept all
of our fasts and deeds that we've done
and may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gather
us
again. of a low head.